o que é isso ou aquilo que lá está e eu
aqui e aí galera
sem ronaldo a vocês hoje estamos aqui em
um lugar totalmente diferente que vocês
vêem aqui no meu quarto e passa os olhos
carro é com vocês sabem ao longo do
tempo a gente vai fazer vital vai
aparecer nas pessoas admiradoras pessoas
que são fãs e e acontecem muitas coisas
inusitadas neco ajeitar de parar com
esse tipo de situação eu sei que é um
cara pra falar e de ter um problema na
cabeça dele que o mundo com vocês caiu
oliveira papá abordaria a apoia só quem
está aqui no canal do windows o que
aliás é muito bom e eu toco para barra
funda oficial
não estou fazendo propaganda não viu e
só poderão se inscrever no canal porque
podem terminar perguntar a ela pois a
gente hoje vai falar sobre fãs
a gente tem muito gosto falar que a fãs
mais admiradores não a gente pensa nessa
vida em algum tempo então tem
admiradores da portonave agora aqui no
meu canto e baile funk na rua tem uma
história de muita gente olhando para mim
com 8 eu vou com você
e como a gente está nessa vida ed de de
aparecer então tem muita admirador e a
gente enfrenta muita situação engraçada
a gente vai colocar o time pra vocês
pelo que você vê no vídeo você já
imagina a sueli que a gente vai voltar
aqui pra vocês não escuta primeira ao
qual foi a situação mais engraçada que
estava no evento é consecutivo já
tentaram pegar atua no twitter o nome
pra tentar dar uma chave fundada na
minha chapa na área e andré lima
engraçado no por alguém falar comigo é o
seguinte tem gente que não liga nem pra
a gente está perto ela chega e faz
sempre
a pessoa nem na casa a gente tira foto
nada agora
isso atrasa a gente com seu objeto em
foco também estavam bastante pessoal
para que a gente conseguisse um objeto
machupicchu 28 outro
o placar com meus fãs uma vez eu estava
em uma calourada de medicina já imagina
a gente acaba aprendendo assim mas é
porque a gente estava agitado biocant
gravar esse é um problema que batavo não
estávamos aqui a cada dia ea imitar
junto eu tô aqui em fortaleza e estava
em teresina não quer me matar vão em
niterói haiti por causa disso aí uma vez
eu estava nessa canoa de medicina já
estava todo mundo bêbado aí a cena foi
mais ou menos assim ligado o cara eu
estava parado o carro começou a gritar
você vai ter jogo que não deu tempo de
ele pegar o celular estava bem e ficou
sem treinar não vai jogar o barcelona
que tem gente que vai tirar foto da com
a gente e gritos do lado da só oito bons
do canal da chave da liga para fernanda
com surdos no meio e assim a gente tinha
e também tem uma tem uma pessoa que às
vezes eu até entendo assim fiquei
emocionada quando a gente por exemplo
tipo eu por exemplo 22 serviço eu começo
a achar rafael e rodrigo santoro também
são um cara que eu sou fã de mais cara
de quem está ali seu ver no meio da rua
começa a voar na memória o inter vai
aceitar não estava a tirar foto e fica
tremendo tal não consegue tirar foto é
fácil eu sou um artista autor faro e
artista pode ser obrigado a nada de nada
am em nada
a roupa se porque fere a igualdade por
tudo é muito heterogéneo goto o povo
desse esse povo heterozigoto demais e em
assim é um crítico andar numa época em
que o treinamento deve tirar novo pode
ser
e essa cena quente a pior que a pessoa
ela é arrastar a quem dela não gosto do
artigo tem como pegar aqui no meu peito
aqui ó pode ser que agora finge que não
é muito amigo pode ser mais carente de
amigos
as amigas tcheca é obrigado ao tse é a
galera sabe aí tá com vergonha bege e
importa é a gente que faz leva entrou em
maracanaú que a cidade vai ter que
fortalecer teve a menina que fizeram um
cordão de isolamento mais poder no
banheiro que era muita gente vinha pela
rua e não pegar mal não é fácil assim ó
e até a chuva fica assim alegando sua
vida e seu treinador
ela fez a chafurdar rodovia tolima herzi
gota pessoas dessa eu fico imaginando a
opção de sair de casa para pegar uma
teta jazz e grilo e olha só a morte do
noivo que é apresentada pelo se você não
sabe para a lógica não é o primeiro na
descrição do vídeo ele se auto esporte
coisas de esportes radicais lá muitas
coisas para você se divertir de motor no
carro e sair por aí vai
à noite na cama no item aranha gente
então aí você pode olhar na canon e tem
várias coisas legais na primeira linha a
inscrição do vírus e da a visitar tenho
certeza que você vai gostar de alguma
coisa lá e olha só se você comprar pela
primeira transmissão do vídeo vai ter 10
por cento de desconto ok ok quando a
fúria tem mais 10 por cento pela firjan
aqui eu comecei é só meu e que aparece
por lá até o canal hora rola alguma vez
alguma coisa diz maior motivação em casa
desmaiada desmaiar
eu não tenho nenhuma agora chora e
faleceu já repete as pessoas diziam vai
encerrar esse tipo de crime cometido não
sai daqui satanás
olho que inclusive já sabe dia 8 e 8
agora o próximo sábado 20 vai estar lá
quem sabe faz sua participação dia de
hoje a valorizar quem vai jogar é o
mortal para trás até agora se você é de
fortaleza sábado às 19 horas a gente vai
estar no via sul e aqui vai estar lá e
lê se você tiver uma vez aparece lá no
teatro em todas as informações aqui em
baixo então isso a gente vai fazer
gustavo da enteada ea gente fez enquanto
fala minha roupa na qual não deixou e
também jorge lorenzo já é tão aí galera
vocês sabem que esse vídeo que foi pra
você
a gente é pedido é caiu junto todo mundo
tá pedindo isso hoje estamos aqui juntos
né contou fala de rivalidade meu deus
cara vocês acham que o nordeste inteiro
não tem lugar para abrigar os
cabeças-de-lista manca ou do doido pra
que a gente ia sair daqui se apertar e
gostei não faz enfiar conhecimentos aqui
dentro de campo não noivo perto e gostei
do que você comente aqui em baixo o
vídeo já foi daí que você mais gosta e
qual é o meu vídeo que você mais gosta
quer saber a opinião de vocês vai tentar
fazer vídeo já que a galera gosta na
época chegando a inter e zina teresina a
gente voltar a aprontar várias aventuras
longas presidente do barulho demandam
não se divertir à beça então é isso aí
muito obrigado a assistir se viu até
aqui se a primeira vez que está
assistindo o vídeo aqui você clica num
inscrever com jeb não sabem né ea gente
vai aí quem tem um negócio ver que natal
se você não conhece meu trabalho claro
que vou fazer aqui uma chance clique
aqui você querer afundar e resposta
quase toda segunda e toda quinta feira
carlos wilson sá além dessa casa bonita
cara contraída no pé tarde feliz
a de rocha